due to various uncertainties surrounding
my position as it relates to the team's
new ownership
i've decided to resign as the head coach
of the new york jets
i've given this decision very careful
consideration i would like to wish the
entire new york fed organization the
players the coaching staff
and the new ownership
the very best of luck for a prosperous
future
i thought there would be any questions
at this point
that's 20 years ago earlier this month
when bill belichick decided he wanted
nothing to do with the woody johnson
regime in new york bill parcells
handing the baton to bill belichick he
held it for a day he wrote it on a
cocktail napkin i'm out yeah later in
the month specifically january 27 2000
the patriots and the jets work out a
trade bill belichick becomes the head
coach the jets get a first round pick in
2000 a fourth rounder and a seventh
rounder in 2001 the patriots get back
belichick a fifth rounder in 2001 a
seventh rounder in 2002 and that was
january of 2000. yeah april of 2000 tom
brady gets selected with a sixth round
pick and he tells robert craft at that
moment the first time he meets him right
i'm the best decision your team has ever
made right is the better decision brady
or is it belichick well i i mean they're
both
amazing decisions that's not the
question but i got to go with belichick
i mean just to go down that i mean you
know again you look at that right now
and go a first a fourth and a seventh
and you got back a seventh and a fifth
for it i mean that's like the greatest
trade ever for one year 20 years 20
years you know nine nine super bowl
appearances won six of them i mean yeah
that's amazing i just still can remember
that going down i think the first thing
that always jumps out to me about that
whole thing there more than anything is
how charismatic if you watch the rest of
that press conference how charismatic
bill belichick was smiling laughing at
people doing that type of stuff where
it's sully he is not that way in front
of the mic but i think that was a
different context yeah okay then because
there's nothing to hide at that point
right there's no broader strategy
i just want the hell out of here yeah
right and i remember thinking that at
that press conference he was kind of
unhinged and rambling a little bit i
didn't know much about him at the time
but i wasn't impressed by that press
conference right now when he gets
introduced as a member of the patriots
he's found his home everything's fine i
still vividly recall because he was five
and 11 in 2000 with patriots right and i
recall listening to espn radio on a
saturday in may of 2001 and mel keiper
was one of the hosts that day and he was
making the case for the 2001 patriots
going winless
and that's that's look we got to fill
the hours with something but that's
where the patriots were after one year
bill belichick nobody knew that
belichick was going to become belichick
nobody even knew who tom brady was at
the nfl level all we knew was he was at
michigan and he was okay but he got
drafted in the sixth round and he goes
into that that churn of backup
quarterbacks that you never hear from
again yeah then all magical changes
magical world changes right and the
world has remained changed for 20 years
yeah six super bowl championships nine
super bowl appearances in 20 years
they're in the super bowl almost half of
the time that belichick's been the head
coach it's amazing it's the greatest
transaction to ever happen in in the nfl
i mean
yeah i do i think it is i think yes i
mean the herschel walker one i would go
as second yeah it set up dallas cowboys
to win three out of four super bowls
definitely uh but
this is like
the greatest football mind in the
history of the sport and it's not even
close and he changed like you're talking
about a franchise who was kind of just a
afterthought into now the gold standard
of the nfl i mean that's everybody is
trying to be the new england patriots
and nobody's gonna be able to do it so
uh just an absolute you know an amazing
coach and yeah that was an amazing time
when that all went down i mean parcells
tried to pull a quick one on belichick
well and in hindsight the team that
benefited the most from the belichick
transaction and the aftermath of it was
the oakland raiders because they were
able to get two first-round picks two
second-round picks and eight million in
cash for john gruden when he had one
year left on his contract right and all
the buccaneers had to do was wait a year
yeah and they would have got him for
nothing right that's how and i think
that you look at the timeline it was
right after the belichick trade turns
into a championship right and the
buccaneers were flailing to find a coach
they almost hired bill parcells right
think about how all these threads come
together they came close to getting bill
parcells mike tannenbaum had already
taken a job with the bucks that's how
close it was it all falls apart and
they're floundering around and gruden
was a hotter commodity than belichick at
that point and gruden delivered a super
bowl in his first year first year but
not
not like belichick i mean gruden paid
off immediately yeah belichick paid off
almost immediately
and over two decades well yeah he's
still paying off well i mean we got into
that 2001 season and they didn't get off
to a great start that year either right
and that's when you know of course blood
so bledsoe had the chest injury and they
were five and five through ten games
yeah that's what i mean you lost in the
regular season you're wondering going
huh i don't know you know what this team
is going to be but they caught fire at
the end of that season and then of
course went into the playoffs won the
tuck rule game went into pittsburgh won
a game there when brady hurt his ankle
right and bledsoe came in and threw it
together
yeah that was that was a a cool moment
but uh and then of course that super
bowl to me was one of my favorite super
bowls ever between you know the clutch
drive at the end with brady the thai law
pick six you know there's just so many
great moments the the greatest show on
turf all that nobody expected the
patriots to be able to pull off that
upset they did it there was
for a little bit of time yeah after the
afc championship a sense that maybe drew
bledsoe
had his job back right because tom brady
got it sure right so came in they won
the game
and and bill belichick shut that crap
down
quickly yeah brady's the guy right that
was the final slap in the face to
bledsoe and he was out the door they got
a first-round draft pick for him yeah
and they got the first round draft pick
back they gave up for bill belichick not
a bad not a bad trade you move on from
the quarterback you were done with
anyway you got tom brady now but yeah it
was it was a strange time because we we
had no idea that the patriots were going
to become the patriots that they were
going to win three in four years and
then they'd have a 10-year gap before
they go on another run of three more in
four years yeah right and and aren't
here it just feels weird that they're
not the one of the teams in the state it
does i i agree i've had i've had moments
over the last week where i go man this
is weird not talking about the patriots
i mean they yeah they've become such a
mainstay here at this event and yeah you
know hey again i'll say it i was partly
sad when they lost on wild card weekend
it's like i is at the end of a dynasty i
don't know what to think i don't know
where the patriots are going to be going
forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports